let's play the angle game so i've drawn
this crazy figure here and i'm going to
give you a couple of angles and then i
want you to figure out another angle so
let me give you some angles so let's say
that
this angle up here
make sure i'm using the right tool let's
say this angle up here
that is 56 degrees
56 degrees
and then i also tell you
this angle here
is 115 degrees
115 degrees
and what i would like you to figure out
this is the object this is the object of
the angle game
i want you to figure out
what this angle is
right here
if you are brave you can pause the video
and try to figure out yourself
if if you would like me to walk you
through it and maybe i give you a couple
of steps and you pause it and you get
the rest of it by yourself but i will
now show you how i would have solved
this in the angle game and and you have
all the tools necessary to already solve
it and i want you to be able to get good
at this because this is this is kind of
like the key skill in the sct
so let's see oh i didn't give you a key
piece and free you're probably saying
sal i can't solve this and it's you
probably can't because i haven't given
you a key piece of information
this line here and this line here so
this line and this line they're parallel
see i was telling you to solve it before
giving you a key piece of information
that means that they are parallel so
what can we do with this figure so
whenever i see these type of problems
either while playing the angle game or
on say an sat i just literally
kind of
figure out every angle that i can figure
out and slowly try to make my way to the
the goal angle so let's see what we can
figure out here so i'm gonna i'm gonna
do it in this blue green color anything
that i can
figure out
so this angle is 56 degrees right
and let's see these lines are parallel
this line here looks like a transversal
a transversal so what do we know about
well let's see what's the corresponding
angle to this angle right here
well it's this angle right
and what do we know about corresponding
angles for parallel lines when you have
a transversal well that's 56 degrees
56 degrees right because corresponding
angles are equal we get a lot of other
stuff we could figure out that this
angle is 56 degrees but that probably
wouldn't have gotten us closer to our
goal
we could have you know that angle is 56
degrees and its corresponding angle is
also 56 degrees that wouldn't have
gotten us any closer to our goal we
could have figured out that this is 180
minus 56 right which is what
124 degrees that really wouldn't have
helped us much but i'm just showing you
these are all things that you can do
while playing the angle gain but anyway
the first step i said well these are
corresponding angles so that's 56
degrees so let's see i need to figure
out this angle right here i know this
one
and they're in a triangle right you see
this triangle if only i knew this angle
if only i knew this angle
can you figure out this angle
well it is supplementary to this 115
degrees right so this green angle plus
this purple angle is equal to 180. so
this is 180 minus 115.
so what's that 180 minus this is 65
degrees
65 degrees so what have we done so far
we just said well these are parallel
lines so corresponding angles are equal
so this 56 degrees is equal to this 56
degrees
and then we said well
this green angle and this purple angle
are supplementary so they have to add up
to 180 so if this is 115
then this is 65 which is just 180 minus
115 right
and i think you you might see where i'm
going now now we know
two sides two angles of a triangle and
if we know two angles of a triangle what
can we figure out about the third well
we know the angles in a triangle add up
to to 180 right so we know let's call
this x
we know that x
plus
equals 180 right and what's 56 plus 65
this is where i always mess up on the
addition and the subtraction so 5 plus 6
is 110 100 this is 121 i believe
121 right because 71 right 121 equals
and then x is equal to let's see 180
minus 20 is 60 so it's 59 x is equal to
59 degrees
x is equal to 59
degrees there we go we have accomplished
our first goal in the angle game
and there you saw it so let's do a let's
do a tougher a tougher angle problem
this one maybe won't involve parallel
lines but i just want to show you
everything really just boils down to
everything we learned about parallel
lines and and
and triangles and angles adding up to
each other so this one involves a star
let me draw the star
so
let's see get a line from there there
draw a line from there to there
now what do we know about this well we
know that this angle is 75 d oh boy i'm
using the wrong tool this angle is 75
degrees
we also know that
this angle is 75 degrees
we know this angle here
is 101 degrees
and your mission in this angle game
is to figure out
this angle
right here
what is this angle and this is a good
time to pause because i will now show
you the solution
so what can we do here so this angle
well geez i just like to just mess
around and see what i can figure out so
if this angle here is 101 degrees what
other angles can we figure out we could
figure out well we could figure out this
angle we could figure out a bunch of
angles we could figure out that
this let me switch to color for these
are my figure out angles
so that's 101 then this is supplementary
that's 79 degrees right that's also 79
degrees
right because this is also supplementary
this angle right here is opposite to it
so this angle right here is going to be
101 degrees
what else can we figure out
we could figure out this angle right
because supplementary we could figure
out this angle we could also figure out
this angle because we see this triangle
right here
this angle
plus 75 plus 75 is going to equal 180
right
so this let's call this angle b
b for blue
so b
plus
75 plus 75
is going to equal 180 right and i'm just
using this
this triangle right here
so b
plus 150
is equal to
or b is equal to 30 degrees so we're
able to figure this out
now
what would you do if i told you that we
are now ready to figure out this yellow
angle
and it might not be obvious you can have
to look at the triangle in the right way
and the sat will do this to you all the
time all the time and that's why i'm
testing you this way
well let me give you a little hint
look at this triangle
i'm using not ideal non-ideal color let
me do it in red so it really stands out
look at this triangle
i'm telling you the hardest thing about
these problems is just looking at the
right triangle and
kind of seeing that oh wow you know i
actually can figure out something
look at this triangle right here
we know this angle of it is 101 degrees
we know this angle we just figured it
out it was 30 degrees
so all we have left is to figure out
this yellow angle let's call it x
right
so x plus 101
x plus 101 plus 30 is equal to 180
degrees because the angles in a triangle
add up to 180 degrees
so x plus 131 is equal to 180
x is equal to what's 50 is what 49
degrees
there you go
we've done the second problem in the
angle game
i think that's all the time i have now
in this video in the next video maybe
i'll do a couple more of these angle
game problems see you soon